Speaker 1: All right.
I want to show you another one of these really
dumb gas prices conversations.
And I'm so sick of this stuff.
And unfortunately, sometimes the left does
it as well.
Former New Orleans Mayor Mitch Landrieu is
now a senior adviser and infrastructure coordinator
to the Biden administration.
He went on Fox News yesterday and was interviewed
by Fox News host Bret Beyer about gas prices.
And they basically just got into pointing
the finger at each other about the same game
that both sides play with gas prices.
And Brett Beyer says to Landrieu, you're giving
Joe Biden credit for the gas prices going
down.
But when they went up, you said it was Vladimir
Putin.
And Landrieu says to Brett Beyer, well, you
guys on Fox News, when the gas prices went
up, you blame Joe Biden.
And now that they go down, you don't give
Joe Biden the credit.
And both are sort of true.
And it's part of what makes this also very
stupid things quickly.
Speaker 3: One is that you mentioned that
the president you're giving the president
credit for the gas prices going down.
But when they went up, it was Vladimir Putin
and the Ukraine war.
Well, we can say it another way.
When it went up, you guys accused him for
making it happen.
And when it went down, you forgot to give
him credit for it.
So.
Well, I'm going to go share it with you.
It started going off before the Ukraine war
started.
Speaker 1: Right?
It actually started going up before Biden
was even president.
Right.
I mean, that's that's the funny thing about
it, which is if you the game that Brett Beyer
wants to play is one that ignores that the
gas prices were actually going up under Trump
as well.
And in fact, I believe I have the chart here
which I can show you.
And if you take a look at this chart, let's
look at the.
Yeah, here it is.
So if you look at this in at the bottom for
gas prices was like late April of 2020.
So gas prices go up.
In June.
And then they go up and up and up and up.
And so the what happened was that there was
a demand collapse during COVID and then gas
prices started going up and then the Ukraine,
Russia war and all these different things
and every country was affected by it.
So Brett Bayer is playing the exact same game
here that they all play.
But that that that that is.
Speaker 3: Let me let me say this to the other
thing that's happening is when that when the
price of a barrel goes up, the price of gas
goes up.
And when it goes down, it doesn't go down.
And the president called it out.
And we need to work on that, too, because
it's the American people that ought to benefit.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Yeah.
So you guys get the point.
I mean, I wish that they would just follow
my lead and say, hey, you know what, Brett?
Let's not play these games.
Gas prices are a global issue related to global
supply, and only in a small way do presidents
make a difference on oil, on gas prices.
And by the way, in the United States, we have
extremely cheap gas compared to other countries
in the United States, we don't accurately
price a gallon of gas to actually reflect
the true costs, including the environmental
costs.
It's subsidized.
The entire thing is a joke.
And, you know, if it were me, we should be
moving to electric vehicles.
But I know that that's not exactly what they
can say at every opportunity, but they're
both correctly pointing to the fact that the
other side plays the exact same game.
Abandon it.
Do what I've done since George W Bush.
Gas prices up under Bush doesn't really have
much to do with Bush.
Gas prices down under Bush doesn't really
have much to do with Bush, although he actually
did invade Iraq, which at least has some connection
to oil.
That is more than what any other president
could could actually be could be attributed
to other presidents.
With Obama when the gas prices were extraordinarily
low, I said it's nice, I guess, for drivers,
but it doesn't really have anything to do
with Barack Obama.
Same thing under Trump and this is what you
get.
Nobody wins from this conversation.
They each try to make their political point.
They each try to say the other side is playing
a political game and they're all it's all
true.
They're all doing it.
But we learn absolutely nothing.
Hey, this was a very strange moment yesterday.
Joe Biden incorrectly said that he has cancer
and this was hours before we learned that
he has COVID.
But this was apparently just sort of like
he used the wrong word and said had rather
than have cancer.
But this set off a firestorm and frenzy of
did Biden just casually admit to having cancer?
Speaker 2: My mother drove us and rather than
us to be able to walk.
And guess what?
The first frost, you know what was happening,
you had to put on your windshield wipers to
get literally the oil slick off the window.
That's why I had so damn many other people.
I grew up have cancer and why can't?
For the longest time, Delaware had the highest
cancer rate in the nation.
Speaker 1: So he does say I and so many other
people I grew up with have cancer.
He clearly means had in his particular case
and immediately multiple reports coming out
saying what on earth is Joe Biden talking
about?
And the White House saying it's a reference
to when he had skin cancer years ago, mostly
right wing media outlets initially jumping
on it.
One of the first reports was from the New
York Post, which is owned by News Corporation.
Joe Biden says he has cancer thanks to the
oil industry, but the White House points to
skin cancer.
Years ago, President Biden said Wednesday
he had cancer, forcing the White House press
office to clarify.
He's referring to skin cancer treatment he
had before taking office last year.
It's unclear what that type of cancer specifically
has to do with oil, but just sort of a confusing
hour or two.
The Washington Examiner also White House denies
Biden has new cancer diagnosis.
The President Biden's latest presidential
bill of health notes that prior to entering
office, he had a number of cancerous lesions
removed.
Quote, It's well-established.
Biden spent a good deal of time in the sun
in his youth.
He's had several localized, non-melanoma skin
cancers removed with Mo's surgery before he
started his presidency.
There are no areas suspicious for skin cancer
at this time and I guess quickly resolved.
But a few moments there of serious confusion.
We've got the clip you can make of it what
you will on our Instagram, which you can find
at David Pakman show.
After this short break, I will be speaking
to Arthur Brookes.
Arthur Brookes was last on the show like 15
years ago when he was a professional right
winger.
He is in a much different area of practice
at this point, I guess we could say.
That's after the break.
Remember Tuesday, July 26th is our next viewer
town hall.
I hope you'll join.
Everyone's welcome to call in and speak to
me.
It will be streaming live on the Pacman Live
YouTube channel, YouTube.com slash Pacman
Live and it'll be at 6 p.m. east 3 p.m. west
Tuesday, July 26th